all right welcome back to CBS mornings
it is time for a very special edition of
talk at the table so special we had to
move to town
a lot of things and we're joined by the
co-host of the talk
of you here in New York together I
imagine when you were driving Jerry you
were talking about you need to go to the
bathroom I could see Akbar and Amanda in
the back like if you I'm going to turn
around
[Applause]
who was the first one to say Are we
almost there yet
it is really funny taking a trip with
your co-workers because you really see
them in a different
environmentally on the plane immediately
pulls out the book
is one of the headphone guys just
sitting here
Sherry the last person to get on the
plane
Jerry when you're the last one on the
plane then all the bends are full yeah
that's right that's why I like to be I
try not to trample little children to be
the first
I wouldn't get that that overhead
I also want to be first because I want
to be in my seat yeah I have a drink in
my hand let everyone walk by
I've got
I've got a topic here I don't think you
guys have heard about it it's the Chris
Rock special it was a slap last year at
the Oscars I don't know if you heard uh
and he talked about it for the very
first time uh and the reaction has been
pouring in um and Cheryl you actually
reacted you all did yesterday at the top
of the show uh and reaction's been
coming in from comedians yes was this a
great bit of Comedy not just an
interesting reaction to a public event
and Cheryl as a comedian what'd you
think I thought it was not only just
great comedy but he made great points he
differentiated himself from other Comics
but he was true to what we know Chris
Rock to be it was bigger black it was
bring the pain it was everything we
needed him to do at the right time he
did it at the right time in the right
way whether you like the jokes or not
don't judge it just enjoy it just enjoy
it and he got it to do it on his own
terms as his own timeline that's which I
thought was very important I also think
it's interesting that he has not talked
about it if I were Chris or the Smith I
would not say another word about it to
anybody that's how everybody is said
what they wanted to say that's right
this go ahead I was going to say this
part of this idea we were talking about
earlier where he says I'm not going to
be the victim right yeah right right I
thought that was also interesting but
he's been saying that from the beginning
I'm not a victim here right you're not
going to see me as he said I'm not going
to be doing crying interviews with
anybody that's right yeah
well believe me I have asked
all right Jared I don't know if you at
the very end when he dropped that mic I
thought to myself we have a video of
that I just thought he looked so
relieved
I thought he looked really relief it's a
tight shot you got to go to the tight
shot at the end where he's looking up at
the audience right here and and they
come back and he's just looking up I
just thought finally he just yes
and I mean to do this and then it's done
I mean I bet that relief was also very
smart yes comedy was very smart so well
it was a big deal too the build the
build up and the anticipation to this
everybody was waiting on their seat I
know I was I was sitting there taking
notes and just you know because I didn't
know if they were going to stream it
again I thought it was just if this was
oh it was a one-time one-time thing so I
was making sure I got down all the stuff
uh but it was really good and the title
selective outrage yeah I think you know
that was a very good point very good
point and the the wokeness and the
outrage against wokeness I mean that was
sort of the theme throughout the whole
thing it was he narrated The outrage
that I think lot of people are feeling
don't you think that this also opens the
door for Eddie to do his set he worked
so Chris wrote this set for a year so he
comes and does it on Netflix and they're
streaming it right come on Eddie Murphy
yeah
I might have sat and come out
do not tease us with a good time
I talk at the table it's about cell
phones first Apple big shout out to
Apple they're getting into spring
they're getting
High color and it's yellow yellow by the
way just happens to be my favorite color
okay did they possibly know that is that
a color option for the iPhone 14 and the
I plus it's yellow and it's spring and
I'm thinking there's a lot of benefits
with it number one if you trade in your
uh iPhone 11 and above you get for this
it's free you still have to cause you
still have to pay for the plant yes you
have 11 and above I think and this has
the longest battery life of anything oh
but I think a bigger question for all of
us who are parents sitting here the big
decision on when to let your children
have a phone iPhone or whatever
how old are you how old are you so I
have 14 year old uh and 11 year old and
I've got a 21 year old so he doesn't
count because he has a phone yeah but my
14 year old and 11 year old twins do not
have phones right now but I am about to
break and I told them they wouldn't get
one until the 11th grade but now I'm
about to break because I just realized
that that's the way their their friends
and everyone communicate and so for me
to hold that back so I have to train
them I'm treating it like a vehicle so
it's like a car you can't just throw
them in there you have to kind of show
them the rules show them the way and
then hopefully you're tough yeah I know
I mean because I think Elvis it's still
a little too young but but I do think
that now I would say I didn't let mine
have one until they were 13 now the
world we're living in I would give it to
them as soon as they start school
because I look at it as a safety issue
and you can program it in ways that they
don't have access to all the stuff you
can get a very simple phone where all
they can do is call in and call out but
you can program it but now for me it's
more of a security issue that's why do
they like you at your house
it's my rules but I will say I did this
with my my oldest son and he took it to
his friend and he I mean deprogrammed
the phone and put up a new whatever so
all the restrictions we had were all
gone I'm like how did you do this
yeah all those kids are geniuses so I've
come up with a whole new solution that
my kids won't like but hopefully they'll
enjoy them what about you uh I have two
14 year old daughters we got phones for
our kids when we got like sick of
talking to them
like just aimlessly just look at Tick
Tock all day long
that was I wanted to be able to
communicate with them and that was about
fifth grade sixth grade you know we used
to we they grew up in Hoboken New Jersey
so the minute they could walk from
school yeah but it was safety for you
yeah safety yes that's how I look at
knowing that they got to school safely
and getting that text always was
reassuring and educational yeah remember
we had encyclopedias yeah
yeah so it's safe it's education we had
the whole set yes I still do at home
yeah it's still right there yeah yeah
yeah
all right so let's talk about the talk
yeah let's talk about the talk yeah
Cheryl let's start with you you're the
OG this is
what season on the show talk about the
chemistry the chemistry you all have now
this is they're so fun and we text each
other we hang out with each other we
have so much fun but it's like a a
championship basketball team we have no
look passes you know even when we have
guests come in or guest co-hosts come in
we just put them in with the family this
is the this is the best feeling in the
world it's better like male co-hosts too
for the first yeah
change yes yes so refreshing having
their perspective it was missing in
daytime yes
we appreciate being invited to the
conversation you know oftentimes it was
one of those things where my manager who
I was saying for years man I would love
to do something like that because I
would watch the shows
um and I would be arguing on the TV
there's another side to this yeah so but
now that we have this kind of this
holistic feel just you know both
different you know aspects to it so so
yeah you know what's something really
special we do before we go on set every
morning is we hold hands and we pray and
sometimes sometimes this morning
just brings us together and and and
makes us a united front and it's it's
really a beautiful moment it's it's kind
of like if we're one of us is running
late and you miss prayer you're like
by holding hands like it's our way of
just connecting connecting before we go
out online shout out to Cheryl too for
giving me the uh the shortest Prayer in
the Bible
that's when we have like hey 30 seconds
to air we're like all right and Jesus
weapon
that's the clip where Nate was praying
with us
when it was there last week we got to
get you two guys yeah I would love to I
gotta bring my wife back to L.A the
closest thing we have in the morning
prayer is when Gail walks out she says
all in our places
[Applause]
ready to go ready to go okay now that
you're doing double duty yes yeah 48
Hours as well so gotten I have one
coming up April 8th we'll do my next one
I'll be here for that yes double duty
doesn't scare you clearly no no I mean
you know I'm used to it I love it get me
in the mix and get to play on a lot of
fronts and Jerry it just seems perfect
for you yes this format you know we have
a really good time if some thing happens
we get to come out and talk about it the
thing I love about doing a show every
day as we come in in the morning and
someone does my my hair has never looked
better
like every day I come home and my wife
is like wow you look really good because
someone has like
this guy when you're naturally good
looking
for children
Amanda you yeah you're always cheering
you on Amanda always I want to see you
guys around New York City you got to do
that tour
you guys should come with us oh
the talk air is weekdays at two o'clock
Eastern one o'clock Pacific right here
on CBS and it's live I love all live
stuff and our streaming service
Paramount plus all right